[Music]
since April 5th 2023 Universal's the
Super Mario Brothers movie has been
running in cinemas most of the feedback
has been positive which was already
reflected in the reactions to the
trailers that have been released so far
in this video we take a look at the
ending and post-credit scenes that the
more patient viewers we're able to enjoy
it goes without saying that there is a
high risk of spoilers for those who
haven't seen the movie yet and for all
the others enjoy this video at the end
of The Amazing animated movie we see
Mario Luigi Princess Peach Donkey Kong
and their companions taking on fan
favorite Bowser for good he has
ambitious goals and wants to take over
the world by means of a superstar
fortunately Mario and Luigi succeed in
reaching the star before him which makes
them Invincible for a certain period of
time and prevents Bowser from harming
them through teamwork they eventually
overcome the villain and with the help
of a blue mushroom he even shrinks to a
harmless size the danger seems averted
after their work is done the two plumber
Brothers return to the Mushroom Kingdom
and celebrate the important Victory it
is directly noticeable that the two no
longer go back to their native Brooklyn
but decide to stay in the Mushroom
Kingdom from now on they work there as
plumbers after proving that they can
save Brooklyn many more challenges await
Mario and Luigi anyway besides there's
hardly any better PR for their plumbing
company than defeating a dreaded villain
Mario's choice to stay in the new
environment was probably not entirely
unselfish either after all this way he
is even closer to Peach for whom he
still has a crush the question of all
questions in today's Blockbusters is
often is there an actual post-credits
scene or not in the case of Super Mario
Brothers this can clearly be answered in
the affirmative strictly speaking there
are even two scenes after the official
ending the first scene occurs relatively
soon after the end of the somewhat more
elaborately animated credits you see the
defeated Bowser and how he suddenly
starts singing about his plans of
Revenge however he's actually caged and
still shrunk to a tiny size as you can
see throughout the scene by putting the
focus back on Bowser right after the end
of the movie it's more or less confirmed
that he'll be making a comeback in an
upcoming movie or possibly even a series
despite being the bad guy he's
considered a sure fan favorite in fact
the filmmakers seem to have put a lot of
effort into his character his
appearances are definitely a highlight
of the film the second post-credits
scene takes much longer to appear than
the first which is why some fans might
have missed it after the end of the
credit we are shown a scene that
obviously takes place in Brooklyn again
suddenly we see a very familiar egg that
without question indicates the imminent
arrival of Mario's friend Yoshi the
dinosaur is known from numerous games
and could easily deprive Bowser of his
rank as a fan favorite thus those
responsible will surely prepare an epic
introduction of the dinosaur also
interesting is the fact that the egg is
located in Brooklyn and thus in our
world this could be a sign that this
location will continue to play a
significant role and that future
Adventures won't take place in the
Mushroom Kingdom only the movie offers
plenty of connecting factors for further
films and series and it's not
far-fetched to think that Universal will
set up an entire universe after the
movie's huge success video game fans
could also profit from the current hype
and perhaps bring forth another game
developed in the style of the film after
the Italian plumber has featured in as
many as 200 games another game seems
pretty likely we are definitely excited
to learn more about the future of Super
Mario Brothers and will continue to keep
you up to date in our weekly news
[Music]
foreign